Hogwarts Legacy has not shied away at
all from the Dark Side of magic in the
Wizarding World if anything it appears
dark magic will be featured quite
prominently in the game given how much
attention the Avalanche marketing team
has devoted to it the original Harry
Potter series was known for its twists
and having characters take surprising
turns from Severus Snape and his role as
a double agent to Remus Lupine and his
true identity as a werewolf to Sirius
Black who ended up being Harry's
Godfather after we first thought him a
murderer an ultimate traitor to Harry's
parents we've been introduced to a
handful of Hogwarts Legacy characters so
far but which ones could actually end up
surprising us and be evil here are five
characters who could turn out to be evil
in Hogwarts Legacy we'll start with
Professor eliezar fig who's described as
both our friend and Mentor in a Hogwarts
Legacy Playstation blog post we also
know he's been investigating rumors of a
goblin Rebellion which doesn't sit well
with the ministry of magic at the time
having a mentor turn out to be a foe is
a familiar Trope and one we've seen even
in the Potter series before one of the
most notable examples happens in Harry's
fourth year at Hogwarts with Professor
moody or fake Moody that is in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire Harry
quite enjoys Moody's style of teaching
but is shocked and appalled to find out
that at the end of the book Moody has
been leading him right to Voldemort all
along and his true identity was Barty
Crouch Jr a Death Eater for Voldemort
many fans have speculated about figs
since his initial reveal but is there
anything we've seen so far to actually
back up the claims that he could be evil
well truth be told there's not a lot but
there is one head-scratching moment in
the trailer during Fig's confrontation
with the goblin ranrock the trailer
clearly wants to position ranrock as the
bad guy here but in this scene we'll
find our main character and fig
appearing to be in Gringotts they're
then confronted by ran Rock and two of
his guards but notice it's actually fig
who strikes first only after his initial
attack do we see ran Rock retaliate with
powerful magic of his own to be fair to
Fig we don't know what happened in the
lead up to this moment but I've always
found it pretty interesting that he
strike first if not fig though what
about one of the other professors such
as Professor heckett considering all the
drama that played out with the defense
against the dark arts post during Harry
Potter's day this one may be a bit too
on the nose then again the problems for
this position started thanks to a curse
from Tom Riddle when Dumbledore didn't
give him the job and yet the name heckit
is likely inspired by hecatee or hekate
the Greek goddess of magic witchcraft
the Knight Moon ghost and necromancy the
closest thing to necromancy in the Harry
Potter series comes in the form of
inferior which are animated corpses of
the dead but in theory aren't
resurrected Spirits rather they are
essentially puppets controlled by a dark
Wizard and this is the most important
Point here inferior are not naturally
occurring in The Wizarding World they
only show up under a powerful spell with
a dark wizard at the center of it of all
the witches and wizards we know about so
far in Hogwarts Legacy it's Rookwood who
probably seems like the most likely
candidate but we also can't discount
Professor heckett either of all the new
characters that have been revealed for
for Hogwarts Legacy we arguably know
more about Sebastian sallow than anyone
else at first glance Sebastian appears
to fall perfectly in line with a
stereotypical rebellious Slytherin he
appears to have a habit of breaking
rules and being somewhat of a rebel it's
even been confirmed Sebastian will lead
us down a path into Dark Magic by
offering to teach us one of the
unforgivable spells and yet he certainly
has a compelling reason for doing so his
twin sister Anne suffers from a
debilitating curse and Sebastian
believes there's a path to save her but
only with the help of dark magic so
while Sebastian may be the one teaching
us at least some form of dark magic I'm
not sure we'll ever see him as a truly
evil or malicious character in the game
in fact his story gives me hope that
Hogwarts Legacy will feature plenty of
gray characters with complex moral
dilemmas when it comes to our actions as
a player I wouldn't be surprised if
Sebastian's Arc ultimately concludes
with us seeing some of the Slytherin
house traits in a new light another
student who could very well be led to
the dark side is Nat's ionai our
companion from Gryffindor natsai began
her schooling in Africa where she attend
ended wagadu the largest Wizarding
School in the world she moved to
Hogwarts when her mother became the
Divination Professor we also know natsai
is wise quick-witted and possessed of a
need to seek Justice what isn't clear is
if her seeking of justice is part of her
personality or if there's something
deeper in her past that fuels that
desire we get a small glimpse of this in
the cut scene featuring natsai and the
main character this is the one that was
showed during the Autodesk presentation
in this scene it appeared the two were
after some sort of evidence we can
actually hear Nats I say new plan I get
the evidence and you free that
hippogriff agreed this is our chance go
yeah
and of course the big question here how
far will she go in the name of Justice
could it lead her down a dark path now
for our next character the first
impressions are pretty much the complete
opposite of evil poppy Sweeting is
soft-spoken has a love of magical
creatures and belongs to the house
Hufflepuff even her last name is
Sweeting but could Poppy's soft first
impression conceal something much more
Sinister a power that could rival even
the likes of Grindelwald and Voldemort
honestly probably not right and again
there is this the official social media
accounts posted this image of poppy
which looks much older and angrier than
the sweet innocent poppy were introduced
to in the trailer she believes creatures
have far more redeeming qualities than
most people and has a particular
aversion to poachers and those who work
with them so on one hand she seems like
a wonderfully gregarious Hufflepuff in
the vein of Newt scamander but could she
have a darker side darker than Newt
particularly if she Witnesses magical
creatures being harmed and what if those
harming the creatures were someone close
to her such as a fellow student could
she even be tempted to use an
unforgivable curse on them for doing so
evil poppy has essentially become a meme
with the hardcore Hogwarts Legacy fandom
but there's no doubt a young Hufflepuff
girl turning to the dark side would
shock many mainstream players now while
I still don't think it's likely I
certainly would not want to find myself
on Poppy's bad side if you're a fan of
the darker side of the Wizarding World
you'll want to check out the latest
addition to our retro Recon tour item
shop visit retrorecouture.com click
merch and get your unforgivable curses t
or hoodie just in time for Halloween and
after that you can check out my full
breakdown of the Haunted hogsmeade shop
trailer here on the right side of your
screen which absolutely does not shy
away from the horror elements in the
Wizarding World as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon